I think you should do a professional but
we can't right now she's not at us
because we cut her hair
[Music]
hi this is oatmeal ah we think she's a
Maltese and a poodle mix so she is
called a multi pill
she's flying and playful our groomer has
been closed she has all of these knots
in her ears
she's a little trim on the behind my dog
journey journey it is a golden retriever
so she doesn't need to be cut with
clippers or anything this girl really
loves to be dirty she is just going to
be cleaned up in a lot of various places
so she could have a proper golden
retriever with our dog's name is
Crickett and she did Supermarine and we
think we adopted her I think she might
have some Maltese no she is coming she
has a personality like you know she
cares she looks like my dog's name is
bear
he is a su Lhasa Apso bear is super
playful I feel like he's a little status
boy other people think he's like a
British soldier or an old man his hair
tends to like grow into his eyes and
this is gonna be very interesting fruit
now I already know that I'm gonna do
better than Chris Evans they don't have
to use clippers so she will not be
walking away with bald patches our dog's
haircut will be better than Chris Evans
because he did not do a very good job
sorry Christie love you was a boy you
got the Clippers I'm gonna put out a
towel I'm like we watched a couple
videos about how I've also never held a
pair of flippers ago like I didn't even
know which way to put that we literally
do not know what we're doing right so he
started and he like I thought the
harlech back part of her body was like
okay but then when Whitney starts to
like for underside it kind of got scary
she was not happy and she was I think
almost got Clippers said they would cut
through the mass and they did not use
I have a groomer that comes to the house
so I am going to attempt to do what she
does just from what I've seen
so I bought a buzzer and it says super
easy with turbo mode and my plan is to
brush them further someone set him on
the kitchen counter okay move your leg I
already know I might have to headlock
him to get his eyes and then hopefully
that'll kind of just like get out the
Wiggles and then I'll be it would just
like buzz oh you're doing so good
we're doing this dream we're doing this
and we're getting it over with because
I'm tired of messing around
doing this at ground level is really
hard and my back is aching and my knees
were hurting don't judge me but I have
my kneepads from when I played
volleyball in high school I'm gonna be
down on journeys level a lot for this
haircut so I'll go about the new one
chunk down oh okay I feel like I judged
Chris Evans a little too harshly because
this is really there's so much bird she
still needs more
so you trust me that I'm not gonna do
anything I'm surprised he's turning just
acting like congressional I was so
surprised he was falling asleep I
thought this was gonna be like deep
breaths headlock holding him down no he
was falling asleep I messed up her foot
I don't I should have watched more than
ten seconds but something ain't right
with her foot journey why can't you
stand like this golden retriever so I'm
the key couldn't purple the areas of
where her personality is you don't want
to take that kind of stuff down too low
so I'm glad I was able to do it myself
and make sure I didn't do too much in
certain areas but yeah that was
definitely definitely harder than I
thought it was gonna be so this is what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna try thrown away
so you stick this to the wall somehow
put some peanut butter in it and it gets
stuck in these little crevices and it
takes the dog forever to lick it out and
hopefully it'll keep over busy while I
try to cut her here I think the good
thing about having a curly-haired dog is
that you can't tell if it's super
botched I posted a video on Instagram
like six people message me know like you
know the groomers are open right you
really didn't know who did not
apparently they are so we are taking her
this weekend to get to the craft to get
fixed
she did not enjoy it was not enjoyable
for us I know everyone's public and
judges for doing it but she looks
mangled and okay so final thoughts oh
can see a little better around her eyes
so that's good but her head definitely
looks shrunken I'm so desperate to get
back to her old groomer because it was
hard I will say that leave it to the
professionals
journey and I both had gloves
today I couldn't let her look good and I
did it definitely a win but she looks
good I didn't get it perfect by any
means but she looks really clean in like
sleek which is exactly what I wanted oh
you like your new haircut they do a
better job than mommy oh you look so
much better
I'm sorry butchered you better we're
sorry sorry his fur is like the really
soft carpet like you can just read from
your hand back and forth this way looks
like now he doesn't look like a hot mess
I honestly think that I'll continue to
do that poem because when I was using a
stylus it was a very stressful
experience for him I use falling asleep
it's just way more relaxing and less
stressful all around so I'll probably
just keep doing myself I've covered in
fur but I'm very proud of myself
[Music]
[Applause]
you